balance between business and personal in
my family is it okay just being okay if
you're happy with okay I think it's the
ultimate yeah I mean I I would argue
that that is the basis of everything I
believe in
like you know I think it's I like having
ambition I like advancing I like working
on things that I'd like to be better at
I love chasing goals and dreams I think
the thing I struggle with is that I'm so
at peace at all times and I'm desperate
to find ways to communicate of what if
you're if you're achieving what you're
talking about You've Won
yeah I'm really just you know looking to
provide as much value happy to answer
anything any insights any
relationships or things that I might be
able to be help of but I just appreciate
all of you being here it's like super
fun to
you know travel around the world and see
what people are up to make connections
make relationships
um you know obviously I've been you know
it's it's like really genuinely surreal
to be going around in a circle and you
know and hear what people are doing in
their careers because when I wrote my
first book crush it in 2008
the hypothesis was like people could
make a living
like the big statement in the book was
like and people might be able to make
six figures on YouTube and literally the
first 100 reviews on Amazon were like
you're a [__] idiot like nobody's
ever gonna make money on YouTube and
social media and so and now it's like
obviously a very scaled profession in
reality and many people here live it so
it's um it's kind of crazy to be OG in a
game even though it's such a young game
and obviously have a lot of insights
given what I do for a living so thrilled
to share them
happy to give anything I got for all of
you so you can just fire away and we can
chop it up what's your prediction for
the next decade like if you were to make
your Crusher book again what would you
say
you know I I tried not to Force
predictions so
nothing's as clear like when I wrote
that book it was clear to me that this
was going to happen
um I think what is clear is a lot of the
next version and the card version some
of you will evolve into this
you know when I started empathy wines
um four or five years ago the concept of
a personal brand using the platform to
create a product like a true consumer
product not like a t-shirt not like a
like a scaled consumer product was a
little bit foreign we built a pretty
large business we sold at the
constellation it was a really
substantial exit but that's a minor
League's execution to what we're seeing
with Mr Beast chocolate and Logan and
ksi's energy drink and so I think what's
very clear to me is the biggest
consumable brands not fashion not
apparel like not like what we've all
kind of seen for the last five years I'm
talking like the biggest potato chip in
the world that is competing with Doritos
or the biggest bottled water or the
biggest bubble gum I think is going to
come from humans not corporations and so
that's a big thing that's clear to me
um I think that uh
I think the AI metaverse thing is an
inevitable outcome I don't know if it
gets fully there within 10 years things
go fast and slow it can be fully there
but but there's really a path for it not
to be there
um I'm interested but in that
um I think the biggest competitor to the
space of creators is virtual creators
so right now a lot of people in this
room are disrupting
actual celebrities and actual you know
and enjoying it so much you know all the
tick-tockers and creators in this room
and around the world are like yeah like
we're getting the action like we're more
famous than the famous people I think
the next decade the fact that AI
personalities and
you know vloggers that aren't even human
beings
um are going to make the current
influencers really sad
because they're going to take the
business so what what this group
represents taking away from Hollywood
and mainstream celebrity
it's very clear to me that
virtual personalities are going to take
that business
and so that'll be interesting
so there's seven things I'm thinking
about
um in terms of like how the U.S market
dominates in terms of like media do you
see
in the next 10 years in changing as to
like U.S power being kind of desaturated
where like Saudi Arabia becomes a really
popular like southeast Asia becomes much
more prominent in terms of like where
the detention focus is because people
get safe at the top of your mind on top
of your music it's like 50 Spanish
already which is changing on a global
scale and then there's like Philippine
songs coming in and then there's all
these other places yeah
I think it's a really good observation
I'm very bullish on the decentralization
of Hollywood being the dominant play the
world is getting much more Global right
like you know the the Latin movement
has a lot to do with the fact that the
U.S
demographics are much more Latin than
ever but on the flip side you know I
think Saudi Arabia is going to be an
importer of it for a long time and
somebody's got a lot of money and so
saudi's game is less creating it and
more buying it which is why you see what
they're doing with golf or Ronaldo or
you know have very Deep Pockets to buy
culture
um but I think what's going on in
Colombia you know the whole Bad Bunny
you know like you know J Balvin going
way way back to even like early JLo
Ricky Martin and Gloria step on going
back like the Enrique Iglesias like it's
very clear that
when you have when you have 14 year old
white kids in America
obsessed with K-pop and obsessed with
music they don't even understand the
Spanish language there's [__] that's
changing and you know America's overall
dominance
in currency and pop culture is
definitely on the decline because
there's just so much more I mean China
has its you know own scale India is
going through its own nationalism
movement so that will happen America
itself demographically is changing
social media allows for anybody not just
someone who flies to LA and makes it in
Hollywood to pop so yeah I think that's
in full pledge
I don't think Saudi Arabia is big enough
or organic enough to be the place where
it comes from they just have they're
gonna buy it
who just said like top threes
well China is really a true market in
itself because it's so big right making
it in China and never leaving China is
very viable
um
you know I think the most to a much
further prediction out I think the most
vibrant interesting content is Africa I
think Africa is going to be a major
player in 24 some this may not be
exactly right but
something like in 2040 35 of the people
25 and under will live in Africa
so it's an incredibly vibrant
um wildly talented similar to like what
we've seen in Southeast Asia or Latin
America like it's on the super come up
in the way the Middle East I think was
over the last 25 years and so I expect
super like I I always say to my friends
of like black coffee is the preview not
the anomaly and so I think you're gonna
see global Superstars Coming Out of
Africa in a big way that would be the
place and a little further out in a five
or ten year window I think you'll see
continuation of what we're seeing now
uh pardon my ignorance I'm not sure if
you have children I'm not sure about how
many others in the room I have four kids
I know you talk a lot about like regret
and mindset and stuff like is it
personally all right like I'm content I
know the whole the seminar and a lot of
today's talk about earning more growing
your business like the balance between
business and personal and like family is
it okay just being okay if you're happy
with okay or do you think it's I think
it's the ultimate
it's the ultimate peace
make more money earn more money status I
don't
know it's I mean of course
yeah I mean it's
it's the biggest reason I talk about the
things I'm a businessman and I love
business but
I think it's crazy to chase money
you know as a singular kpi
mainly because the majority of people
that I know that are wealthy or not
content
yeah cool yeah I mean I I would argue
that that is the basis of everything I
believe in
I you know I think it's I like having
ambition I like advancing I like working
on things that I'd like to be better at
I love chasing goals and dreams but
I think the thing I struggle with is
that
I'm so at peace at all times and I'm
desperate to find ways to communicate of
what if you're if you're achieving what
you're talking about You've Won
like to me waking up with anxiety is
like devastating
it's it's so challenging like being
anxious and being concerned and being
worried those are tough
you know
you of course it's I know you know it's
okay
right thank you you know what I mean
like how do you manage like with all
that you do I couldn't even because I
feel like I'm absolutely flat out and
like just pulled between so many
different things it's tied in a little
bit to the two things for me what works
is the balance of hunger and ambition
with complete and utter content which
equals it's like a formula hunger and
ambition
you know plus
wild content equals
the ability to not judge myself for
making mistakes
so the reason I could handle so many
things is if you're trying to do 98
things like I do that brings me great
joy I love the chaos of of playing on
many fronts you have to be completely
comfortable with losing a lot many
things I try and work on don't succeed
and if you're not comfortable with that
and you are worried about people's
Judgment of your failures well you'll
never do a lot of things
you'll only do one thing when people
like I'm a perfectionist I'm like you're
scared
you're not a perfectionist you're scared
of judgment
what do you think with a I'm sorry man
no I know you're right what do you think
when your three uh keys to success on
your successful exit of empathy not
necessarily Revenue historical
historical leverage yeah I grew up in
the wine business and everybody knew me
in that world
uh
two was my two partners started as
interns and had been with me for 10
years before we started the company so
full family execution
you know just like full trust full
alignment same page so I can dancing to
the same song yeah
and three a very contemporary marketing
plan and execution that was very
valuable for consolation for all their
brands not just empathy so it was a
scalable model that they could use for
their overall business so by just buying
the company they were Roi positive right
away because we immediately impacted all
their business not just empathy
those three
another thing to add as well you're
saying um what I find struggling the
hardest as well is as an artist like
literally I was a builder for 10 years
and then I um went to Mexico for a
little surf trip and decided to be an
artist and came back they're not
literally all I do every day I sit up
paint insert and that's all I do and
I'll get to the end of the day and I
feel so dark saying [__] this is like
pretty hectic it's my life and you're
sort of in that depression where it's
like I don't deserve this how do you do
you ever get that and do you feel what's
the best why do you feel like you don't
deserve it it's still like uh because I
was a building you know how hard it was
and then now it's like I'm painting
you're getting contract with these big
companies and you're like I don't
deserve this life this is pretty and I
get really dark about it I want to make
sure I understand one more time you feel
like you get dark because why I really
like you know fights where it's I just
don't feel like that loss
because I'm still you know I get lost a
syndrome or like yeah I don't deserve it
so I sort of get
really down himself and that's what I
was sort of because it's too good and
you don't get a service yeah and it's
like [__] I should be still working hard
because my Mrs is in the Navy so she
works out all the time
well is she sustaining your lifestyle
is she sustaining your lifestyle no no
so then what's the problem I just get
really dark man
do you feel well I think I think well
here's an interesting thing I always
think like there's a lot of
similar feelings that can take two very
big extremes so let me explain what I
mean by that
when I when I hear you talk now that I
understand what you're saying
my place would go into why are you not
leaning into heavy gratitude versus
heavy judgment
instead of going dark why not be super
thankful why not be practical about the
fact that you could literally be
diagnosed with terminal cancer tomorrow
and so just because it's good now
doesn't mean it's going to be good
forever and why not be grateful that
tomorrow you wake up and get to do what
you're doing
you know yeah like I actually understand
the concept of having guilt
like I talk about it a lot that my
energy is based on this weird mix of
like heavy gratitude and heavy and a
guilt of like the luck of the DNA and
circumstances that built me to who I am
but I think you're giving guilt too much
energy and not enough to gratitude
you know what I mean and then the other
thing is what you may want to do is
contribute so another thing that I'm
thinking about is you know one of the
things that really gives me tremendous
peace of mind is I have this incredible
framework of gratitude but I've been
like bleeding for the last 15 years to
try to impact others in a positive way
through storytelling you might be able
to add
a scenario to in between surfing and
going to painting if you articulate what
if you break down that trip to Mexico
over and over and over again you might
be able to inspire someone to have their
version of Mexico for them to be happy
you know there's when I when I think
about how grateful I am for being as
happy as I am it always is more palpable
when I read my DMs or emails in the
morning where people are giving me roses
for really helping them
and so maybe you need that right now
because maybe it's you're feeling
inherently too selfish my missus is
doing this you're not doing anything for
the world maybe adding is maybe what
you're thinking I don't know yeah
I wonder I wonder you know your trip to
Mexico is profound you just sat here and
said I was working I went to Mexico and
I came back and was an artist
like that's [__] rad and I wonder if
there's an opportunity for you to really
really bring you know what I do for a
living now professionally from a Content
creation standpoint is I've spent
thousands of hours dissecting my life
and its experiences to try to articulate
in different ways with different
adjectives on different platforms of
like what's the insight to that and how
could that actually matter to someone
and if they can make a connection of
like oh that's me too maybe that can
lead to their thing I think you should
really consider to try to like storytell
about that trip because it's profoundly
interesting
you might Inspire someone and maybe that
will scratch the itch that you're
feeling right now emotionally which
would be rad
because then you're taking something
that right now is eating you up and it
can turn into a very positive energy
I would try that
incredible like the honest
we have a lot of artists
how do you balance right making your art
about fitting the market and what it is
that you want internally to express
because like I got it it's it's it's my
biggest pain point that people can't
wrap their head around and
I just think that you can do both this
is why I believe in volume so much
it's not 1984 where you can only put out
one album every three years because you
had to [__] press it on a [__]
disc like like it's the internet like
put out a [__] song that is
completely trend on trend on trend on
Trend because you want to you didn't
sell out you wanted to make something
that was on trend
and then make a [__] ballad where you
pour your heart out that you know isn't
commercially viable because you need to
scratch your or like this concept that
you're not allowed to be both commercial
and have depth is insane to me
we're obsessed in the world of war
no no I'm not confused about Lil Wayne
because he put out a rock album
it's it's these philosophical things
that are old school they're Theory
what people give a [__] about is do I
like this [__] song or do I connect
with this song You Know You're not like
oh like like fans well like they ebb and
flow anyway like you know how it is your
earliest fans [__] with you then you get
bigger than you've sold out
then they miss you and they come back
then you disappear for a while they
really miss you then you come back
they're like back but then it's not good
for them anymore in your different life
cycle like like I I just know this to be
true because I in my craft of content
creation like people like
Gary I don't [__] with your [__] anymore
I'm like that's great like I'm so
humbled that I was ever a factor in the
first place and then those same people
four years later like yo I'm back and
I'm like of course like because we've
matched up again you know
yeah I think those are so historical
points of view because of the limitation
of distribution but now we have
unlimited distribution and the only
thing you're doing is not getting out
what you want
by sitting and debating this all that's
happening is in action
right
right it's look look at those back to
back things you know he's thinking
through his feelings if if he acts on
putting out what I just said like
there's only action
similar Point like on the fans
and show up on creators about converting
them converting short form viewers into
fans and people
engaged of course
of course
yeah I mean I think I think the biggest
problem for a lot of people is they
don't convert because they're intent and
or talents don't convert
I'll explain hey Gary I'm Tick Tock I
want to have subscribers to YouTube but
they're not good at YouTube
they're good at Tick Tock but not
YouTube like they're not good at
blogging but they are good at Tick Tock
or vice versa then so that's the ability
the talent like there's a very different
art form of making short form tick tocks
than there is in making them seven to
thirteen minute video those are just
different different crafts so one
sometimes that's the hard part the other
part is intent I think the biggest issue
right now for a lot of creators and
influencers up when they Plateau is they
Plateau because their talents have
gotten them to whatever that is they're
attractive they're funny they they can
be a musician they can sing like
whatever it is whatever their talent is
humor Beauty a skill their talent goes
to a certain place they Plateau because
they're selfish
everything's about for them
Gary I want to convert this audience to
buy tickets I'm like okay
like what are you doing for them
and so I think we're in an era right now
of selfishness at scale
and when I analyze what's happening who
continues to grow when they plateau
I can see a direct correlation from what
I do for a living which is that there's
a there's an extra gear of trying to
bring value or filling a void that is
above and beyond the surface level part
of their skill set
you know what I mean I think for
everyone here if you literally posted
something tomorrow
with the full framework of why is this
good to some for somebody why is this
good for them
and entertainment
is powerful
like
it's massive why are models like like
beautiful people bring value like I want
to look at this I want to listen to this
I want to see this but you've got to
continue that framework and eventually
when you keep doing the same thing it's
oversupply against it you've they've
seen that and what most people do is
then they get stuck and they start to
get sticky or they try to jump on Trends
or they're stuck because what they
haven't realized is they now have to
transition to a selfless framework
instead of a selfish framework and
almost nobody's thinking about that
see
every question is how I every question
is how do I monetize my audience
nobody ever asks me like how do I make
it more valuable for my people
I'm sorry what's your thoughts on
building the business at this moment
when there's like so much economical
vulnerabilities there's never a bad time
to start a good business
it's like sometimes you think like oh I
should take the safe side
there's never a bad time to start a good
business to your point you're not wrong
I think that's good like hey high risk
High reward but like if you're going to
build a good business
whether the economy is good or bad
you're going to win
to your point if you don't have a
Clarity that you're building a good
business
it's probably not a good idea to just
guess but I have good news for you when
money's flushing fluttering too
unlimited bad businesses start and fail
so to answer a question don't worry
about the outside economic realities
worry about your capacity or your belief
system in what you're building
got it it's not this is where people get
caught on like where's the money at
what's the trend what's the macro thing
if you don't build a good business it's
gonna like 99 of the businesses two
years ago when money was flowing failed
cause they weren't good
businesses are hard
you know like every like it seems like
it's not because everyone's an
entrepreneur now but everyone's playing
an entrepreneur
can I ask about your health yes
limited energy yes
yes
membership yes
do you do intermittent fasting so as you
know intermittent fasting is much more
on the cultural tip of tongue today
I I have been doing it pretty much my
whole life
what about your
regime
I you know
I used to have somebody travel with me
full time for pre-covered for like six
years and I worked out I was in the gym
every single day
now he lives in Minnesota
we do a lot of stuff virtual
um he's not traveling with me as much
but I'm probably
you know
in this year I'm what are we in in
August like in the last eight months I
probably am in the gym
85 of the days
um I work out predominantly seven days a
week when I'm not traveling and even
when I am I'm usually working out with
him I hurt a pec muscle and and a glute
like I'm a little strained right now so
and this Trip's a little awkward but
yeah I work out quite a bit I do a lot
of soft tissue work that is you know I
don't know if people if you have like a
bad back or stuff like fashion soft
tissue is fascinating you should look
into it but yeah I work out
so you actually encouraged me to move to
New York last year and it's like it's
like my second home at home which I
really like and one of the things that
you said that stopped in marketing
recently is that uio
and I wanted to ask you on that and your
journey and discovering that because
that's been very profound to me thank
you you know as a lot of people here
know like everyone's like you need a
knee short you know like and I'm just
like man like everyone's like struggling
of like I gotta find my Niche and like
everyone's like this sucks there's too
many influencers I'm like but you're one
of the problems like you know like
everybody like everybody like doesn't
want competition that makes me laugh
like as if you're entitled to I'm like
you know like Gary you don't get it like
I used to be I'm like you don't get it I
was doing this before you were born this
was awesome I was like YouTube sensation
when there was 19 of us you know like
um
so I'm glad you picked up on that and it
it's hit a lot of people and I need to
continue to do more content about this
by Nature you as a human being are your
Niche because we're all really really
different if you're willing to go if
you're like hey I'm an artist or a
magician well then you're not but if you
keep going and just saying what else you
are and who you are and what you look
like and where you were born and like
it's just it's niche personified and I
I'm fascinated because I just always go
on what I know is right versus what
everyone's kind of pushing so even my
public speaking career Steve and I were
talking about this on our flight this
morning from Melbourne to here like I
cursed that was super crazy off like
that in 2009 that was just like it what
would you say Steve has grown up in this
game Steve what do you think in 2009
when I was really speaking and cursing
what percentage of gigs did that
immediately eliminate me from
just off top so he worked for a
different company his Steve's one of the
key Executives at Vayner speakers
Zack his teammate was my speaking agent
at CAA and like we talked about the
story of like Zach's boss because he was
kind of like underneath this guy a great
guy Peter and they called me and were
like hey you're starting to like
something's happening for you and we
really think you can be big but you have
to immediately stop cursing and I was
like I have some really bad news I'm
like I'm gonna have to say not that big
because I'm just not capable of like so
I dressed super casual and I'm a
businessman that was crazy like you had
to really wear suit and tie like I was
doing all these things wrong but
everything worked for me because I
became my Niche because I just stayed
it's back to like people throw around
authenticity all the time but they like
but then they're not they like people
compromise their authenticity for the
algorithm
people compromise their authenticity for
the likes
think about that for the followers right
but then if that was true like then the
culture wouldn't be the way if Pharrell
and that whole crew didn't like make
nerd culture cooler like all the rappers
that rock Dragon Ball Z now and [__]
Pokemon wouldn't be doing that it took
their courage because that wasn't cool
like and so like I would tell all of you
like a lot of people are holding in all
sorts of things
sexual orientation Hobbies true
friendship other interests that don't
fit the profile or the Persona that
they've built and the reality is that's
the [__] that's gonna make people love
you
I'm a very real businessman like not
like like I make money as a personality
like I'm a businessman like built bit
lots of big businesses and I'm like
making videos about garage selling and
buying two dollar items
and all my real business friends like
the real business people are like the
[__] are you doing
and I'm like I'm showing people how to
make 55 out of two dollars
and like but this makes you look like
you're like you're like this is [__]
you up I'm like it's not
like I can sit in the boardroom with the
most significant business people in the
world and I can go to a garage sale and
buy a t-shirt for a dollar and sell it
for four bucks and I don't give a [__]
if somebody doesn't want to interact or
follow me because of that or do business
with me because there's so many people
that will and I think everybody here if
they push themselves a little if
everybody here today tomorrow's next two
posts one was I am 100 focused on making
this the single thing that I think can
bring the most value to everybody who
sees it does nothing matters for me and
the next one is I'm gonna talk about
some [__] that nobody knows about me but
that's really me I think it would change
the trajectory of what the majority of
this room is up to
I believe that I believe both posts may
do worse than every post that they're
accustomed to because it's not on best
practices
but I think it will change in a great
way for everyone
I really believe that what's that
hello hello so um first of all uh you
know it's really lovely to actually
speak to you and I want to say thank you
because prior to being part of Dana
everything
um you know your content uh I started I
I don't I started watching you when I
was very like I was very focused on
academics I was very like that was I
didn't give myself a creative Outlet yes
a long time
and um and when I spoke to you last this
was 2022 in garyvee I was thought about
like a crossword clue my chronic illness
was really really affecting me do I do I
go back do I try academics I know it's
not I know I struggle with it with my
body my health all that do I try out
this creative thing and you know your
content you our conversation everything
you know you gave me a lot of courage to
try and be a creative and I haven't
worked with John Henry starnell's brand
illustrator like crazy stuff that's
happening
I think recently like I don't know if
it's being like adjusting 25 or whatever
I don't know if it's the type of career
that it is or if it's just life you know
I feel like I've struggled a lot in the
last maybe two years or so with
uncertainty and rejection you know and
these are things that like I I thought I
was always comfortable with but as I'm
just getting like to this section of
whether it's I know people feel this at
every age but it's like the rejection
even
well that's because
my advice is to understand yourself
somebody that grows up that puts
Academia on a pedestal is protecting
themselves for not being rejected
like fake AKA school once you figure out
the system you can get A's and you can
trick yourself into not having rejection
real life is only rejection
life is only rejection
all life is is micro losing
all life is is Michael
's micro the quicker you can get good at
enjoying micro losing
like the quicker it gets great
and it's important words matter micro
losing not macro losing not losing your
relationships or your house or micro
losing every day I'm micro losing
you just the reason you're struggling is
because you put Academia on a pedestal
your whole life
it's a huge problem it's this is like I
I don't think people understand like how
deep my intent goes I'm not fighting
school because I wasn't good at it I'm
fighting school because I watch the
world and I know what it's doing to
people
it's really really really a challenging
framework there's no flexibility in it
here all six-year-olds we're gonna just
push you through for the next 18 years
16 years 12 years on the same [__]
track and the ones that are lucky enough
to conform to it will make pretend
you're good and all the other ones AKA
anyone who's creative in any shape or
form whatsoever which is more than half
the population we're gonna build
Frameworks to make you feel insecure
along the way that you're dumb and not
good
[__] is that
and and then you have immigrant parents
and parents in general just reinforcing
its value
and then your parents wanting their
children to be doctors and lawyers and
Engineers to make them good and feel
good not you and like who the [__]
watching out for people
right
I'm I'm curious about like uh AI yeah I
was really wondering what or is your
advice or like utilizing that or teaming
up with it or just like anything it's
all coming it will all be real if this
was 2002
the internet stocks all just crashed
everyone's debating if the internet's
even a thing but the internet's growing
by the nanosecond as we sit here today
right now versus 30 minutes ago when I
walked in web 3 is Advanced AI has
advanced what's up
um like all of it like you should stay
on top of it as a viable business you
have to understand the timing
nfts I think are going to be enormous
but right now the brand of nfts is in
the garbage because the greed of last
year crushed it because people weren't
listening to what I'm always saying
which is 99 of everything always goes to
zero like all right like you know like
are sneakers a good collectible and
something people care about of course
they are but 99 of sneakers are not
selling on stockx
but everybody got caught up and they put
like all nfts or you know people like oh
beanie babies but Beanie Babies are a
stuffed animal stuffed animals continue
to sell a trillion dollars squishmallows
are doing just fine
right so like people are not good at
seeing the macro and so right now just
because a lot of people aren't on the
metaverse doesn't mean that it's not an
inevitable outcome of course VR is going
to happen the technology is advancing
too fast the new Apple [__] is [__]
good we're not all the way there yet but
like online dating was good in 2002 but
there was too much taboo to it so people
were like meeting but they were like
lying now it's mainstream so it's all
coming it's just social norms timing
technology but if you're into that [__]
you should pay attention because you'll
PR if you really pay attention right now
and you're actually looking at it every
day you'll have a good sense of when
it's going to Bubble Up Again
if you're not paying attention it's
gonna it's gonna catch you off guard
I gotta go okay pleasure thank you I'll
see you out there
[Music]
thank you